Planet Earth is the home of every
life form known to us in the universe.
It's age is about a third of the age of
the universe and admitted it is a thing
of beauty.
The slightly squash there with a heavy
metal core and a lighter surface crust
wrapped in a fence. Lever of sweet
attar breeze with fast oceans,
fertile plains, magnificent
mountains, freshwater rivers, streams,
lakes and aquifers orbiting a star,
which warms us and gives us energy.
But how did our hope come into
existence and what's it made of?
4.6 billion years ago,
earth was created from the remnants of
dead stars that collected in a giant
dirty gas cloud.
The gas cloud became denser in its
center and formed the accretion desk.
Small particles started clumping together
and building larger and larger objects
until they formed the objects
we call planets. Today.
This process took 10 to 20 million years
and is still not very well understood
that about this time when the
solar system was young and chaotic,
a giant objects about as big
as Mars collided with our home.
The impact was violent and if
the object had been more massive,
it might have destroyed earth.
Material from Earth was smashed
out into orbit and formed the moon,
which is the biggest satellite in relation
to its planet in the solar system.
At this time,
earth was a hot hell,
constantly being hit by asteroids with
seas of lava and a toxic atmosphere,
but something was about to change
drastically. Earth cooled down.
Water from the inside of
the earth wandered to the
surface and rains down on us
only to vaporize again.
Advocacy clouds,
millions of asteroids brought
more and more water to our planet.
All the water on earth has about
this volume compared to earth.
Today, the surface of earth
is 71% water and 29% land.
97.5% is silane water,
while only 2.5% is fresh water.
The fresh water is 69% ice and snow,
30% our ground waters and only about
1% make up the remaining groundwater's,
but even this small part is mostly frozen.
Only a tiny part of our water is actually
lakes and rivers and an even tinier
part is bound in living things so
gradually the earth cooled down and the
surface formed a thin crust,
but inside the earth hot rock continue
to swell about moving the cross from
below and breaking it apart.
This process is called plate
tectonics and is happening right now.
We'll make a whole video about
it in the future. For now,
let's just say that the crust of Earth
consists of separate Joan plates that
move around as they meet,
they crumble and create mighty mountains
or violently plunged back down deeper
into earth,
creating deep trenches.
That's the way the highest
place on earth was formed.
Mount Everest and the deepest, the
Mariana trench. From our perspective,
earth's mountains and
trenches are mighty in deed,
but when you look at the
earth in cross section,
you can see how tiny they actually are.
The part we stand on is the crust,
which is about 50 kilometers thick.
Though it can vary between five
and 70 kilometers. By the way,
the deepest hole ever drilled by man is
12.262 kilometers deep up to the cross,
come to the mantle.
It's a silicate rocky shell and
about 2,900 kilometers thick.
The mental consists of the upper
mantel and the lower mantle.
The upper mantle has different
regions too. It's upper part,
which is a viscous and carers.
The crust is called the lithosphere.
After that there comes the asthenosphere
which consists of less mobile,
mostly solid material.
The lower mantle reaches deep
down to the outer core of earth.
Earth's outer core is a liquid
layer of iron and nickel,
about 2,266 kilometers thick.
Temperatures vary from 4,000
degrees Celsius to 5,700
degrees Celsius and in the
center is the inner core.
It's mostly solid.
The ball made of an iron nickel alloy
with a radius of about 1200 kilometers,
70% the size of the moon, and about the
temperature of the surface of the Simon.
It is slowly growing as an estimated
rate of about one millimeter per year.
Now for some perspective,
this small layer of crystallized milk
products of former molten metal is where
we live.
Then there's earth's magnetic field.
It's an invisible phenomenon.
The diverts high energy particles coming
from the sun and other sources and
knowing for a stable environment with
comparatively little radiation impact on
earth, but why is it there? Actually,
we don't really know a
terrible lot about that.
We know it has something to do with
the core of the earth inside this metal
sphere. Large electrical currents
flow in complicated patterns.
They cause a magnetic field that sort of
stabilizes itself according to the laws
of electrodynamics.
This entire system is called the dynamo,
but don't let us fool you into
thinking we have it all figured out.
Speaking of breathtaking information,
what's about the airy stuff
that surrounds us by volume?
Dry Air consists mostly of
nitrogen, oxygen, Argon, carbon,
a variable amount of water vapor
and small amounts of other gases.
Humans are very dependent on the lowest
layer of the atmosphere. The troopers,
fair weather, weather is it's
12 kilometers thick on average.
Above that is the stratosphere, which is
where the ozone layer protects us from.
The Sun's most aggressive type of light.
Above that is the Mesosphere,
the coolest place on earth with an average
temperature around minus 85 degrees
Celsius. As about 80 kilometers
up the thermosphere starts.
The transition to space is a
fluent one without clear borders,
but Schumann's decided that space
starts here at about 100 kilometers.
Earth stops and space begins though the
atmosphere extends a bit further in this
region,
we find the ion is fair.
The Aurora borealis and the ISS and
the outermost layer is the exosphere
stretching up to 10,000 kilometers.
It merges fluidly without a space
where there's no atmosphere at all.
The atoms and molecules in this area
are so far apart that they can travel
hundreds of kilometers without
colliding with each other. Okay.
Humans in their present form have
only been around for 200,000 years.
That 0.004% of Earth's history,
not non really,
and here we are now living in a thin,
moist layer on a small wet rock.
We call this rug earth.
It is the product to the
university's deepest workings.
The result of the constant process of
creation and destruction happening all
over the universe all the time,
helped by chance the laws of
the universe and random events.
We are really lucky.